Where are you from? No, where are you really from? And hey, your English is good. Many of us are familiar with the idea of microaggressions, the indirect, subtle, often unintentional incidents of racism or bias that members of marginalized groups experience every day. Despite the syllable micro in the name of these phenomena, psychologists have found that experiencing constant microaggressions
你来自哪里？不，你到底来自哪里？嘿，你的英语真好。我们许多人都熟悉微歧视的概念，即边缘化群体的成员每天经历的间接的、微妙的、通常是非故意的种族主义或偏见事件。尽管这些现象的名字中带有“微”这个词，但心理学家发现，经历持续的微歧视
can take a toll on people. people's physical and mental health. In recent years, they've begun to devise strategies that people can use when they experience or witness microaggressions to defuse and neutralize these everyday instances of racism and bias. So what makes something a microaggression? How do microaggressions differ from simple rudeness? What effects do microaggressions have on those who experience them? Why are they so harmful and in what ways? And what should you do when you experience a microaggressions? or when you see one directed at someone else. Welcome to Speaking of Psychology,
会对人们的身心健康造成损害。近年来，他们开始设计一些策略，供人们在经历或目睹微歧视时使用，以化解和消除这些日常的种族主义和偏见事件。那么，究竟是什么让某种言行成为微歧视？微歧视与简单的无礼有什么区别？微歧视对经历它们的人有什么影响？为什么它们具有如此大的危害，又是以什么方式造成危害的？当你经历微歧视时，或者当你看到微歧视针对其他人时，你应该怎么做？欢迎收听《心理学说话》，
the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. My guest today is Dr. Daryl Wing-Soup, a professor of psychology and education in the Department of Counseling and Clinical Psychology at Teachers College, Columbia University. He is a pioneer in the field of microaggression research,
这是美国心理学会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理学科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯。我今天的嘉宾是哥伦比亚大学教师学院心理咨询与临床心理学系的心理学和教育学教授达里尔·温-苏（Daryl Wing-Sue）博士。他是微歧视研究领域的先驱，
as well as in multicultural psychology, multicultural education, multicultural counseling and therapy, the psychology of racial dialogues, and the psychology of racism and anti-racism. His research has helped elucidate the causes and consequences of microaggressions, as well as to devise strategies to combat them. He's the author of nearly 200 scholarly publications and 23 books, and he's won dozens of awards for his research, including APA's 2019, Award for Outstanding Lifetime Contributions to Psychology. Dr. Sue, thank you for joining me today.
同时也是多元文化心理学、多元文化教育、多元文化咨询与治疗、种族对话心理学以及种族主义与反种族主义心理学领域的先驱。他的研究有助于阐明微歧视的原因和后果，并设计出打击微歧视的策略。他是近200篇学术出版物和23本书的作者，并因其研究赢得了数十个奖项，包括美国心理学会2019年杰出终身心理学贡献奖。苏博士，非常感谢您今天能来参加节目。
Well, Kim, I'm pleased to be here, and please call me Gerald. All right, I will do that. Thank you. I gave some examples of typical microaggressions in my introduction a moment ago, but let's dig into the definition in a little more detail. How do you define a microaggression? What kinds of actions or words constitute microaggressions? Well, microaggressions are the everyday slights and dignities, insults, put downs, and invalidations that people of color, if we talk about racial microaggressions, experience
金，很高兴能来到这里，请叫我杰拉尔德。好的，我会的。谢谢。我刚才在开场白中举了一些典型微歧视的例子，但让我们更详细地探讨一下它的定义。您如何定义微歧视？什么样的行为或言语构成了微歧视？嗯，微歧视是日常的轻视、不尊、侮辱、贬低和否定，如果我们在谈论种族微歧视的话，有色人种会在
in their day-to-day interactions with oftentimes well-intentioned individuals who are unaware that they have engaged in a demeaning or offensive manner towards the individual. The thing that makes microaggressions so powerful is that they are reflections of worldviews of inclusion, exclusion, superiority, inferiority, and normality. Almost any marginalized group in our nation can be the object of microaggressions. My research has primarily been on racial micro-micressions. but there are gender microaggressions, there are disability microaggressions, LGBT microaggressions, and so forth.
他们与那些往往出于好意、却没有意识到自己对个人采取了贬低或冒犯态度的个人的日常互动中经历到这些。让微歧视如此具有影响力的是，它们反映了包容、排斥、优越、劣势和常态的世界观。我们国家几乎任何被边缘化的群体都可能成为微歧视的对象。我的研究主要集中在种族微歧视上，但也有性别微歧视、残疾微歧视、LGBT微歧视等等。
The microaggressions experienced by marginalized groups in our society operate under what we found to be the similar social psychological processes, but they're very very social, psychological processes. but their themes are quite different. For example, even within racial, within people of color, African Americans are most prone to experience microaggressions of criminality and dangerousness. Asian Americans and Latinx Americans experience themes of perpetual alien. or foreigner in your own country. If you skip over to gender, sexual objectification is a common theme that women experience in their day-to-day lives. LGBTQ individuals have probably a very
我们社会中被边缘化群体所经历的微歧视，其运作机制符合我们发现的相似的社会心理过程，但是它们的社会心理过程非常非常……然而，它们的主题却截然不同。例如，即使在种族内部，在有色人种内部，非洲裔美国人也最容易经历关于犯罪性和危险性的微歧视。亚裔美国人和拉丁裔美国人则会经历“在你自己的国家里永远是外人”或“外国人”的主题。如果转向性别领域，性客观化是女性在日常生活中经常经历的一个共同主题。LGBT群体经历的可能是一种非常
unusual form because the themes that they experience are themes of sinfulness and pathology. And so while, you know, while the, when we talk about microaggressions, the type of group or population that we refer to oftentimes experience the different themes that tend to put them down or in some way negate who they are as cultural beings. These aren't the same as overt expressions of racism, right? I mean, there are things that people say, where they're unthinkingly, just saying something without even realizing what they're doing is somehow denigrating the person they're talking to, correct? Well, actually, this is very complicated.
不寻常的形式，因为他们经历的主题是罪恶感和病态。因此，虽然你知道，当我们谈论微歧视时，我们所指的群体或类型的群体往往会经历不同的主题，这些主题往往会贬低他们，或者在某种程度上否定他们作为文化存在的本质。这些与公开的种族主义表达不同，对吧？我的意思是，有些事情是人们在不经意间说出来的，甚至没有意识到自己的所作所为在某种程度上是在贬低他们正在与之交谈的人，对吗？嗯，实际上，这非常复杂。
You're asking microaggressions can be overt and obvious. For example, in our research, we find three really forms of microaggressions, micro assault, which is most similar to old-fashioned racism, racial epithets. This is conscious and deliberate. The reason why there is some confusion about this is that the other two classes of microaggressions, which forms the bulk of our studies, are microinsults and micro-invalidations. And these tend to be outside the level of awareness. When you talk about microaggressions, there's a continuum from conscious deliberate all the way to being outside the level of conscious awareness and unintentional. What we find, the reason why we separate this is that we find that those forms of microaggressions that are most outside the level of awareness tend to present.
你提出的问题是，微歧视可以是公开的和明显的。例如，在我们的研究中，我们发现了微歧视的จริงๆ三种形式：微攻击（microassault），这最类似于老式的种族主义、种族蔑称。这是有意识的和蓄意的。之所以对此存在一些混淆，是因为微歧视的另外两类（构成了我们研究的大部分）是微侮辱（microinsults）和微否定（micro-invalidations）。这些往往超出了意识层面。当你谈论微歧视时，存在一个连续体，从有意识的蓄意，一直到超出意识觉察水平和无意。我们发现，之所以把它们区分开来，是因为我们发现那些最超出觉察水平的微歧视形式往往会表现出……
produced the greatest harm. For example, a person who is overtly racist towards me, I know where they're coming from. I can deal with it directly. But the insidious, unintentional microaggressions delivered by people who experience themselves as good, moral, decent individuals is more decent and more difficult to deal with because I'm thrown into a situation where I'm trying to to determine did what I think they meant really happen? Is it that I'm oversensitive, paranoid? And that type of psychological questioning leads to what we oftentimes call racial battle fatigue if we're talking about racial microaggressions because they are there.
产生最大的危害。例如，一个对我有公开种族主义态度的人，我知道他们的立场是什么。我可以直面它并处理它。但是，那些认为自己是善良、道德、正派的个人所发出的潜移默化的、无意的微歧视，则更难对付，也更难处理，因为我被卷入了一种情境中，我试图去确定：我以为他们表达的意思真的发生了吗？是我太敏感了、偏执了吗？这种心理质疑会导致我们常说的“种族战斗疲劳”（如果我们谈论的是种族微歧视的话），因为它们就摆在那里。
And when we try to tell the individual what they've just said, why it was demeaning, they deny that was their intention. Right, right. And they tend to say, you're just oversensitive. That wasn't my intention at all. If I accept their explanation, the danger is that I deny my own experiential reality and accept their explanation. And this is what we call the clash of racial realities,
当我们试图告诉这个人他们刚才说了什么、为什么那是贬低时，他们否认那是他们的意图。对，对。他们往往会说：“你只是太敏感了。我根本没有那个意思。”如果我接受他们的解释，危险在于我否定了我自己的体验现实，转而接受了他们的解释。这就是我们所说的种族现实的冲突，
where racial realities differ between people of color and well-intentioned white Americans who might, like I was saying, see themselves. It's really quite the type of individuals that would stand against racism. So what are the physiological and psychological effects of experiencing microaggressions over time? And for some people, of course, it's their entire life. So what happens to you internally, externally? How does it manifest in your everyday life if you're experiencing microaggressions constantly? Okay.
有色人种与出于好意的白人美国人（正如我刚才所说，他们可能将自己视为会挺身而出反对种族主义的那类人）之间的种族现实存在差异。那么，随着时间的推移，经历微歧视会产生哪些生理和心理影响呢？当然，对某些人来说，这是他们的一生。那么，你的内在和外在会发生什么变化？如果你不断地经历微歧视，它将如何在你的日常生活中表现出来？好的。
You know, that's an excellent question because this also leads to the thought where people believe that the everyday rudeness or insolvilities that people with power and privilege experience, are harmless, trivial, and insignificant. Maybe the person had the clerk that mistreated a white individual, just had a bad day. Just let go of it. It's not that big of issue. However, there are major differences between racial microaggressions and everyday insinilities that are not group-based.
你知道，这是一个极好的问题，因为这也引发了一种想法，即人们认为有权有势者所经历的日常无礼或无理行为是无害的、微不足道的、无关紧要的。也许那个虐待白人的职员只是那天心情不好。算了吧。这不是什么大问题。然而，种族微歧视与并非基于群体的日常无理行为之间存在着重大区别。
For example, as a racial ethnic individual, a person of color, the difference is that I experience microaggressions from the time I awaken in the morning until I go to bed at night. From the time people of color experience racial microaggressions from the time they are born until they die. and is constant and cumulative in that if I was to give an example, which you did at the beginning, about as an Asian American, I oftentimes get complimented for speaking good English. They'll say, Professor Sue, after I give them address, they'll say, Professor Sue, that was really interesting. I just want to compliment you. You speak excellent English.
例如，作为一个种族族裔个体、一个有色人种，不同之处在于，我从早晨醒来直到晚上上床睡觉都在经历微歧视。有色人种从出生到死亡都在经历种族微歧视。而且它是持续不断且累积的，如果我要举个例子（你刚才在开头也举过），作为一名亚裔美国人，我经常因为英语说得好而受到称赞。他们会说：“苏教授，在我对他们发表演讲之后，他们会说：‘苏教授，那真的很有趣。我只想称赞你。你的英语说得真好。’”
Now, that appeared to the person, that's a compliment. But to me, I receive what I consider a meta-communication, which is shock and surprise that a perpetual foreigner, someone who looks Asian, could speak that good English. It denies a fact that I am a part of, I was born and raised here. Now, if you talk about that alone, then a person will say, yeah, maybe the person misunderstood, but Daryl, that's not a big thing. Let's go of it. They don't realize that that might be a microaggression, the third one that I have experienced that day with the same theme, that you are not a true American. and so they become cumulative. Microaggressions are also constant reminders to targeted groups and individuals
现在，在对方看来，这是一个赞美。但对我来说，我收到的是我所认为的元交流信息，即对一个“永远的外国人”（一个看起来像亚洲人的人）能把英语说得这么好感到震惊和意外。这否定了我在这里出生和长大的事实。现在，如果仅凭这一点来谈论，人们可能会说：“是的，也许那个人误解了，但达里尔，这不是什么大事。算了吧。”他们没有意识到，这可能是一个微歧视，是我那天经历的带有相同主题的第三个微歧视，即你不是一个真正的美国人。所以它们会累积起来。微歧视也是对目标群体和个人的不断提醒，
that they are second-class citizens. When you talk about they are also reminders of past historic injustices. For example, the incarceration of Japanese Americans during World War II. They're taking away of land. the indigenous peoples of our society, the enslavement of blacks. All of these are past historical trauma that are conjured up. And as a result, they have a major impact upon both the psychological and physical well-being of individuals. You know, when we, you know, interrupted, if I'm going on and on, but when we published our first major taxonomy on microaggressions,
提醒他们是二等公民。当你谈到它们也是对过去历史不公的提醒时。例如，二战期间对日裔美国人的关押。他们对土地的剥夺。我们社会的土著人民，黑人的奴役。所有这些都是被唤起的过去的历史创伤。因此，它们对个人的心理和生理健康产生了重大影响。你知道，当我们，你知道，打断一下，如果我一直在滔滔不绝地说的话，但是当我们发表关于微歧视的第一份主要分类学时，
and this was in the American psychologist in 2007, many of my white brothers and sisters, colleagues, wrote letters into the editor. And much of what they were saying was that microaggressions are macro-nonsense. That they are harmless, they're no different, like I was saying, between an ordinary insult, and that we were portraying people of color as weak and, you know, overly sensitive and so forth. But since then, there has been, what is it, you know, meta studies that have been conducted indicating the major harmful impact, increased anxiety in targets, increased depression, lowering of psychological well-being when microaggressions occur. And also, you know, we find that.
这是在2007年的《美国心理学家》杂志上，我的许多白人兄弟姐妹、同事给编辑写了信。他们所说的大部分内容是，微歧视是“宏观废话”。它们是无害的，就像我刚才说的，它们与普通的侮辱没有什么不同，我们把有色人种描绘成软弱的、你知道的、过度敏感的等等。但从那以后，已经开展了什么，你知道的，元分析研究表明了重大的有害影响，增加了目标的焦虑，增加了抑郁，当微歧视发生时心理健康的降低。而且，你知道，我们发现……
microaggressions affect a person's ability to learn and to problem solve, affects a person's ability to perform well in job-related opportunities. One of my colleagues at Yale University, Jack DeVille, has done a lot of studies on aversive racism, and he finds what I call microaggressions, racial microaggressions directed at employees of color that it drastically diminishes their ability to perform in a work-related environment. All of these things add up to effects on psychological well-being, physical well-being, education or ability to learn in the classroom and also work-related issues. But what is really what we find is that microaggressions also account for disparities in employment,
微歧视会影响一个人学习和解决问题的能力，影响一个人在与工作相关的机会中表现良好的能力。我在耶鲁大学的一位同事杰克·德维尔（Jack DeVille）对厌恶性种族主义做了很多研究，他发现我所说的微歧视，即针对有色人种员工的种族微歧视，极大地削弱了他们在工作相关环境中表现的能力。所有这些因素加起来，对心理健康、生理健康、教育或在课堂上学习的能力以及与工作相关的问题产生了影响。但我们真正发现的是，微歧视也是就业 disparities 的原因，
health care, and education that they all have this particular impact. That's pretty devastating. So let's switch for a moment then and talk about how to respond to microaggressions because sometimes people might recognize that a microaggression has occurred, but in the moment they don't know what to say or what to do about it. And you and your colleagues have developed what you call micro interventions for those moments. So can you talk about those and what can people do?
医疗保健和教育，它们都有这种特殊的影响。这真是太毁灭性了。那么我们暂时转换一下话题，谈谈如何应对微歧视，因为有时人们可能会认出微歧视已经发生，但在当时他们不知道该说什么或该怎么做。你和你的同事为那些时刻开发了你们所说的微干预措施。那么你能谈谈这些以及人们可以做什么吗？
How can they help? Well, first of all, one of the things that when we first started, our studies on microaggressions and worked with groups of individuals regardless of their race, culture, and ethnicity, the constant question that we had was that, yes, we understand microaggressions, but what do we do? What do we do about it when it occurs in the moment? And this question came not only from targets, but from why? allies and by bystanders or onlookers. When you're made aware that a moral transgression has occurred, most of the people we found felt paralyzed. They didn't
他们能如何提供帮助？嗯，首先，当我们刚开始对微歧视进行研究，并与各类人群（无论其种族、文化和族裔背景如何）合作时，我们遇到的一个常见问题是：“是的，我们理解微歧视，但我们该怎么办？当它在当下发生时，我们该怎么做？”这个问题不仅来自目标群体，还来自白人。盟友以及旁观者或旁观者。当你意识到道德违规行为已经发生时，我们发现大多数人都感到瘫痪。他们没有
know what to do. So we refocused our study to micro-interventions or anti-biased strategies that targets allies and bystanders can engage in to disarm and dismantle microaggressions. And we went to the literature, conducted a number of in-depth interviews with groups about what did they do when this happen. For example, when you get complimented for speaking good English, when you are asked, where were you born? You know, when a black subway rider enters, you know, the subway system, why is it that everyone moves away from them? Why is it that only when you enter the subway that you're tired and you want to sit down
知道该怎么办。因此，我们重新将研究重点放在微干预或反偏见策略上，目标群体、盟友和旁观者可以参与这些策略来解除和瓦解微歧视。我们查阅了文献，对不同群体进行了多次深入访谈，了解他们在发生这种情况时做了什么。例如，当你因为英语说得好而受到称赞时，当你被问到“你在哪里出生？”时。你知道，当一个黑人地铁乘客进入，你知道，地铁系统时，为什么每个人都从他们身边走开？为什么只有当你进入地铁、你很累想坐下时，
that the most likely empty seat is next to a black passenger? Now, these are microaggressions. And microaggressions can be verbal, nonverbal, or environmental. The nonverbal communication by virtue that I'm not going to sit next to a black rider is that there's something wrong with you. You're dangerous. We don't associate with people, you know, like you. Now, we begin to ask individuals, when this happens to you, what do you do or what have you?
最有可能空着的座位是在一个黑人乘客旁边？现在，这些都是微歧视。微歧视可以是言语的、非言语的或环境的。非言语交流意味着“我不会坐在黑人乘客旁边”，因为你身上有问题。你很危险。我们不和像你这样的人交往。现在，我们开始问个人，当这种情况发生在你身上时，你做了什么或者你有什么经历？
done. And we came out with literally hundreds of different actions that can be taken. The problem was that there was no organization. So we began to do what we called a secondary, when it's factor analysis. We grouped all the anti-biased strategies that were similar into categories. And we came up with four different categories in which micro-interventions fell into. The first category was to make the invisible visible. As long as you're unaware as a perpetrator that you have engaged in a microaggression, you're not going to change because you simply aren't, you know, well, I'm complimenting you for speaking good English.
做到了。我们提出了数百种不同的行动。问题在于缺乏组织。因此，我们开始做我们所谓的二级因子分析。我们将所有类似的反偏见策略归纳到各个类别中。我们提出了微干预所属的四个不同类别。第一类是让无形变为有形。只要你作为加害者没有意识到自己已经参与了微歧视，你就不会改变，因为你根本没有……你知道，“嗯，我称赞你英语说得好，
I mean, why are you getting so upset? So making the invisible visible was one strategy. The second strategy was to educate the perpetrator, that there were a lot of responses that were aimed at that. The third category was to disarm the microaggression. And what we found was that oftentimes microaggressions are so unpleasant to begin with the immediate action is that you have to stop it. And the last category was to seek outside support and validation.
我是说，你为什么这么沮丧？”所以，让无形变为有形是一种策略。第二类策略是教育加害者，有很多回应都是针对这一点的。第三类策略是解除微歧视。我们发现，微歧视本来就令人很不愉快，所以即时行动往往是必须阻止它。最后一类是寻求外部支持和验证。
When microaggressions occur, there is oftentimes a power differential between the perpetrator and targeted individuals or group. For example, in academia, one of the things that we found, when we looked at the classroom, and this is something very fascinating. When we did original studies on microaggressions, our intent was to find out microaggressions had occurred within the classroom between students. What we discovered was that the most frequent microaggression came from the professor. And, you know, you can also talk about the
当微歧视发生时，加害者与目标个人或群体之间往往存在权力差距。例如，在学术界，我们发现的一件事是，当我们观察课堂时，这是一件非常迷人的事情。当我们对微歧视进行最初的研究时，我们的意图是找出课堂上学生之间是否发生了微歧视。我们发现最频繁的微歧视来自教授。而且，你知道，你也可以谈论……
this in the world of work, that managers, supervisors. So what happens when the microaggression comes from someone who holds status, power, and privilege over you? There are oftentimes consequences so that last category seeking outside support and help was important here. Under each of these four strategies, we identified about, oh, about half a dozen or more tactics. For example, making the invisible visible. And we came out with one of them was make the microaggression explicit. When the person makes a microaggressions point it out, that was a statement. Now, that was a stereotype.
这在工作世界中也一样，经理、主管。那么，当微歧视来自一个对你拥有地位、权力和特权的人时会发生什么？往往会有后果，所以最后一类“寻求外部支持和帮助”在这里很重要。在这四种策略中的每一种下，我们都确定了大约半打或更多的战术。例如，让无形变为有形。我们提出了其中之一：使微歧视明确化。当一个人制造微歧视时，指出来，那是一种陈述。现在，那是一种刻板印象。
That was a microaggression. And by doing that, you're not doing that, it may cause some discomfort, but you are not saying that you as an individual are racist, but what you just said or done is a microaggression. Should we continue with it thereon? There are other ways to make the microaggression. more visible and explicit. Several years ago, I was working in a school system
那是微歧视。通过这样做，你并没有这样做，它可能会引起一些不适，但你并不是说你作为一个个人是种族主义者，而是你刚才所说或做的是微歧视。我们应该继续下去吗？还有其他方法可以让微歧视变得……更加明显和明确。几年前，我在一个学校系统工作。
with African-American teenage girls. And we would talk about microaggressions, and they, without even prompting, they could name a number of them. Sure. One of the most common ones that they experienced was a well-intentioned white classmate coming up to them and saying, you know, you're pretty for a black girl,
与非裔美国女青少年一起。我们会谈论微歧视，甚至不用提示，她们就能说出好几个。当然。她们经历最普遍的之一是一个出于好意的白人同学走过来对她们说：“你知道吗，作为一个黑人女孩，你挺漂亮的，
or you're pretty for a colored girl or something of that nature. And we began to talk about how do we respond to that and make the person maybe know what's happening here. And they were laughing because they came up with a response that was a superb example of a micro-intervention. Janet, a white student, goes up to Ayesha, a black student, and says, you're pretty for a black girl. Ayesha says to Janet, thank you, Janet.
或者“作为一个有色人种女孩，你真漂亮”或类似性质的话。我们开始讨论如何对此做出回应，并让对方可能知道这里发生了什么。她们笑了，因为她们想出的回应是微干预的一个极好的例子。珍妮（Janet），一个白人学生，走到阿依莎（Ayesha）——一个黑人学生面前说：“作为一个黑人女孩，你真漂亮。”阿依莎对珍妮说：“谢谢你，珍妮。
You're pretty for a white girl. Now, you know, the microaggression here is that you're pretty for a black girl. is that most blacks aren't pretty, aren't attractive, that you are an exception. And by reversing that, what they found was that many of their white classmates, when confronted with that, would step back. And I've learned, for example, that someone comes up to me,
作为一个白人女孩，你也挺漂亮。”现在，你知道，这里的微歧视是“作为一个黑人女孩，你真漂亮”，意思是大多数黑人都不漂亮、不迷人，而你是个例外。通过扭转这一局面，她们发现许多白人同学在面对这一情况时会退缩。我了解到，例如，当有人向我走来时，
you know, usually a well-intentioned individual and says to me, Dr. Sue, you speak. excellent English. I will say, John, thank you. You do too. Now, you know, that reversal, now there's a lot of these strategies that are used that aren't necessarily aimed at confronting. And, you know, for those of you are interested, we have publications and books. In fact, I have this microaggression toolkit. I think it was written not been giving specific examples under each of those categories. And educate the perpetrator as a strategy.
通常是一个出于好意的人对我说：“苏博士，你的英语讲得真好。”我会说：“约翰，谢谢你。你也一样。”现在，你知道，这种反转，现在有很多这样的策略，不一定是为了对抗。而且，对于感兴趣的人，我们有出版物和书籍。事实上，我有这个微歧视工具包。我想它里面写了针对每个类别的具体例子。并将教育加害者作为一种策略。
Again, there are many, but the most basic aspect of educating the perpetrator is separating out intent from impact. You know, oftentimes when you point out a microaggressive person will say, but that wasn't my intent at all. Right. You know, and if you take the person on the battleground in terms of intent, you've lost the battle, because you can never prove intent. But you can do something that has changed the field of where the discussion occurred
同样，有很多，但教育加害者的最基本方面是将意图与影响区分开来。你知道，通常当你指出时，一个有微歧视的人会说：“但这根本不是我的意图。”对。你知道，如果你在意图的战场上与对方较量，你就已经输掉了这场战斗，因为你永远无法证明意图。但你可以做一些事情来改变讨论发生的领域，
and say something like, I know you meant that to be funny, but it really hurt Joanne or it really hurt as such and such. I know you mean well, but think about how your words did. What you've done is, you've separated out the intent from the impact so that you can now talk about the impact and get the person to work back in terms of understanding what might have gone on. These micro-interventions are not meant to be long-involved actions. They are meant to stop almost like in a game of a chest.
并说类似这样的话：“我知道你的意思是想开个玩笑，但这真的伤害了琼恩，或者真的伤害了某某。我知道你是好意，但想想你的话造成了什么影响。”你所做的是，将意图与影响区分开来，以便你现在可以讨论影响，并让对方回过头来理解可能发生了什么。这些微干预并不是为了进行长期的、涉及广泛的行动。它们的目的是阻止，几乎就像下一盘棋一样。
You check the behavior. And it can be as simple in terms of disarming. the microaggression is something like, you know how when people step on your toes, you say, ouch. Right. You know, and so someone says that, you know, those people are always so lazy. Ouch. It's a response you made.
你遏制了这种行为。就解除微歧视而言，它可以很简单，就像你知道当别人踩到你的脚时你会说“哎哟”一样。对。你知道，所以有人说：“你知道那些人总是那么懒。”哎哟。这是你做出的回应。
It does several things. It may be simple, but it indicates the person who made the microaggression, your disagreement. and the fact that it isn't the way you perceive the situation. You don't have to get into a long, elaborate argument with the individual. And the last type of micro-intervention is a category that I've indicated, seeking outside support and help. It is oftentimes, there are major, there may be major, two consequences to you pointing out a microaggression, especially if there is a difference in status and power relationships. You know, to the professor who makes a microaggression
它有几个作用。这可能很简单，但它向制造微歧视的人表明了你的不同意见，以及这并不是你看待情况的方式这一事实。你不必与这个人进行漫长、详尽的争论。最后一种微干预是我指出的类别：寻求外部支持和帮助。通常情况下，指出微歧视可能会带来重大的两个后果，特别是如果地位和权力关系存在差异的话。你知道，对于一个制造微歧视的教授，指出来，嗯，你可能会得低分。你可能会被贴上麻烦制造者的标签。如果你是一名员工，而经理制造了微歧视，那么指出来可能会让你失去升职、加薪或别人对你的看法。这就是你必须开始思考自己拥有哪些社会支持和盟友可以帮助你应对这种情况的地方。如果你是一名有色人种员工，而白人经理对你进行了微歧视，并且你注意到这个人不会接受你的指出，你可以去找另一位你与之关系良好的经理，也许可以争取那个人的帮助，让他们来进行讨论。但还有很多事情。
to point it out, well, you may get a bad grade. You may be, you know, labeled a troublemaker. If you're an employee and a manager makes a microaggression, well, pointing it out can cost you that promotion, that raise, or perception that you have. This is where you have to begin to think about what social supports and allies do I have that can help me address this situation. If you're an employee of color and a white manager makes a microaggression against you, and you note that this person is not going to be receptive to you pointing that out, you can go to another manager who you have a good relationship with, maybe enlist the aid of that person in order to have them have a discussion. but there are many things.
而这最后一种策略，有色人种和女性往往会指出，这是我软弱的表现。我必须说服他们：当你们准备好了再去战斗，并使用对你们可用的策略，不要认为这是在背叛你们的正直感。因此我们发现，当我们让人们接受这种培训时——而且必须进行培训，因为仅仅指出可以做什么是不够的——它必须成为个人自动发生的一系列反应的一部分。因为微歧视是如此自动、发生得如此之快，以至于等你考虑该怎么做时，它已经结束了。
And this last strategy that oftentimes people of color and women tend to point out is that it's a sign of weakness on my part. And I have to convince them that fight your battles when you're ready and use of strategies that are available to you, don't think about you, you know, betraying your sense of integrity. And so we have found that when we put people through this training, and training has to be done because simply pointing out what can be done isn't enough. It has to become a part of the person's repertoire of responses that occurs automatically. because microaggressions are so automatic, occur so quickly that by the time you consider what to do about it, it's over.
因此，然而，如果一个人在讲种族主义笑话并说到笑话的包袱时，如果你能立即说：“哇，我们别去那里，有危险，前方有流沙”，或者“我不确定我想听那个包袱”并走开，这是非常有力量的，因为它让那个讲笑话的人保持警惕。但微歧视往往发生在大量观众面前。如果每个人都保持沉默，这种沉默可能会向旁观者或围观者传达“这是可以接受的”的信息。但如果你进行干预，你告诉大家“我认为这不可以”，并且你为其他人树立了榜样，展示了可以采取什么行动来结束、解除或……
And so, however, if a person is telling a racist joke and getting to the punchline, if you can immediately say, whoa, let's not go there, danger, quicksand ahead, or I'm not sure I want to hear the punchline and walk away, It is so powerful because it puts that jokester on guard. But microaggressions oftentimes occur in front of a large audience. If everyone remains silence, that silence may communicate to bystanders or onlookers that it's okay. But if you intervene, you tell people, I don't think. it's okay and you model to other individuals of what actions can be taken to end disarm or, you know,
阻止微歧视的发生。而且，你知道，当我们研究微歧视时，我们研究了所有负面影响。我们开始研究微干预，并发现了积极的宏观积极影响。例如，对目标群体最具破坏性的事情之一是无力感、无助感，甚至是自我鞭笞。“你当时应该这么说。你当时应该这么做。你是个懦夫。”然而，当我们教给他们微干预技巧时，我们发现他们感到自己更有力量，并且他们的自尊心
stop the microaggression from occurring. And, you know, when we studied microaggressions, we studied all the negative impact. We began to study micro-interventions and we found positive, macro-positive impact. For example, one of the things that are so detrimental to targets is a feeling of powerlessness, helplessness, and even self-flagellation. You should have said this. You should have done that. You're a coward. However, when we teach them micro-intervention skills, we find that they feel empowered and their selfishness.
和自我概念有所增强。我们在白人盟友身上也发现了同样的情况。现在，一个听到种族主义笑话的白人可能会不赞成，但他们不知道该如何处理。所以他们也觉得自己的行为与自己的价值观不一致。然而，当他们参与微干预时，这验证了他们的正直和内部价值观。对于旁观者，当我们教给他们微干预时，他们会增强我们所说的批判性意识、批判性觉醒。旁观者往往不知道微歧视已经发生了。
and self-concept increases. We find the same thing with white allies. Now, a white person listening to a racist joke may disapprove of it, but they will not know how to deal with it. So they, too, feel that they are acting inconsistently with their own values. However, when they engage in a micro-intervention, it validates their integrity and internal values. And with bystanders, when we teach some micro-interventions, they increase what we call critical awareness, critical consciousness. bystanders oftentimes don't know that a microaggression has occurred.
他们会认为那只是一个赞美。那只是一个好笑的笑话。但一旦你开始培训，他们就会培养出这种意识，从而开始改变他们看待世界和其他人的方式。这些都是发生的积极事件。因此，特别是在过去几年里，我认为关于微歧视的讨论已经走出了学术界，成为了关于种族和种族主义的更大社会对话的一部分。我认为，对于整个概念出现了一些反弹。其中一个批评是，关注微歧视使得人们更难就种族和族裔进行公开和诚实的对话，因为他们担心无意中犯下微歧视。
They would think that's just a compliment. That's just a funny joke. But once you begin the training, they develop this awareness that begins to change the way they see the world and other people. And these are all positive events that happen. So in the last few years in particular, I think the discussion about microaggressions has moved out of academia and become part of a larger societal conversation about race and racism. And there's been some backlash, I think, to this whole idea. One criticism has been that focusing on microaggressions makes it more difficult for people to have open and honest conversations about race and ethnicity because they're worried about unintentionally committing a microaggressions.
你对此有何回应？你知道，我不相信这一点。让我告诉你为什么。其中之一是，有色人种一直被迫保持沉默。而言论自由的一部分就是指出微歧视的能力.虽然它可能对有色人种产生直接影响，但本质上，感觉如履薄冰总比茫然不知、对正在发生的事情视而不见要好。所以我老实说，你之所以对正在发生的事情感到如此自我意识过剩，是因为你陈旧的、
How do you respond to that? You know, I don't believe it. Let me tell you why. And one of them is that people of color have always had to remain silent. And part of free speech is the ability to point out microaggressions. And while it might have immediate impact on people of color, in essence, feeling like I'm walking on eggshells is better than obliviousness and not acknowledging what is going on. And so what I honestly say is that the reason why you feel so self-conscious of what is going on is that your old,
如果真心想进行自由、公开的对话，那些有害且具有破坏性的反应和行为方式已经不再适用了。你之所以感到如此大的困难，是因为你必须学会以开放和不防御的方式谈论事情的新方法。这直接指向了我们的另一系列研究，即关于种族对话、沉默的阴谋的研究。我写了一本书，并对此做了一系列研究。我们发现，白人承认并公开谈论种族问题本身就存在困难。我们所做的研究是：为什么人们如此难以就种族问题进行公开和诚实的对话？我们找出了导致这一现象的四个不同层面。首先，
ways of reacting and behaving, which have been harmful and detrimental, are no longer functional if you really want to have a free, open dialogue. The reason why you're feeling so much difficulty is that you've got to learn new ways of talking about things in an open and non-defensive of manner. And this goes directly to another series of research that we had, which is on race talk, the conspiracy of silence. And I did a book and a number of studies on it. And we find in some way that there already exists difficulties in white people acknowledging and talking openly about race. And the studies that we did was that why is it so difficult for people to openly and honestly dialogue on race? And we came up with four different layers that created. First of all,
最外层是人们感到害怕，嗯，有权有势的人最害怕公开谈论种族问题，因为他们担心自己所说或所做的一切会让自己显得具有种族主义倾向。因此，他们采取了我所谓的“战略性色盲”，或者通过假装你看不到差异、避开种族话题、绕过整个话题来谈论，这样你就不会显得具有种族主义倾向。社会心理学家发现的问题是，通过这样做，你会陷入所谓的“修辞语无伦次”（rhetorical incoherence），采取防御策略的人会口吃、结巴、含糊不清，这反而让他们显得更具种族主义倾向。当你问某人对跨种族关系的看法，而他们却在绕圈子时，信不信由你，他们反而显得更具种族主义倾向。所以这是我们帮助个人克服的第一层。但还有第二层。
the exterior layer is that people are afraid, well, people with power of privilege are most afraid of talking openly about race because they're fearful that whatever they say or do will make them appear racist. So they engage in what I call strategic colorblindness or by pretending you don't see differences, avoiding a racial topic, you know, talking around the entire topic so that you won't appear racist. The problem that social psychologists found was that by doing this, you engage in what you call rhetorical incoherence, that from the person who is taking protective strategies that they stammer, they stutter, they are obtuse, it makes them appear more racist. When you ask someone, how do you feel about interracial relationships and they talk
我不确定我是否有时间谈论这个。第二层是对你确实怀有种族偏见的恐惧，因为这挑战了你作为善良、道德、正派个人的形象。对他们来说，可怕的事情在于，是的，你可能是一个反对公开种族主义表达的人，但突然不承认自己怀有刻板印象和偏见的事实，会彻底打破这种形象。所以你必须克服这一点。然后我们发现的第三个层面是白人特权这一整个领域。
around the topic, believe it or not, they appear more racist. So that's one layer that we work with individuals to get through. But then it's a second layer. And I'm not sure I have time to talk about that. The second layer is the fear that you do harbor racial biases, that It challenges your image as being a good, moral, decent individual. And that is the scary thing for them that, yes, you may be one that have stood against overt expressions of racism, but to suddenly not acknowledge a fact that you harbor stereotypes and biases shatters this image. So you've got to work that through. And then the third level that we found was this whole area of white privilege.
一旦你经历了前两个层面，第三层就是对精英统治神话的挑战。有时，通过你自己的努力和工作，你取得了成功，而你却否认了白人身份和白人特权是让你起跑并在这个方向上前进的未劳而获的好处。最后一个层面，我快速讲完这个，因为我知道我们时间不多了。最后一个层面可以用这句话来概括：终极的白人特权是承认你的特权却什么都不做。这是第四个层面，即成为（你知道的）非种族主义者与成为反种族主义者是不同的。这是珍妮·赫尔斯（Janet Helms）的工作，她谈到你可以经历所有这三个层面，
That once you go through the first two levels, the third level is the challenge of the myth of meritocracy. That sometime to your own efforts and work, you've succeeded, and you deny whiteness and white privilege as the unearned benefits that made you start and move in this, you know, forward here. And the last level, I'm going quickly on this, because I know we're losing time here. The last level is summarized in this statement that the ultimate white privilege is the ability to acknowledge your privilege and do nothing about it. this is the fourth level, which being, you know, being non-racist is different from being anti-racist. This is a work of Janet Helms that talks about you can go through all three of these levels,
但由于后果的理论和威胁，仍然不采取反偏见行动。我们现在的研究确实是在寻找克服这些恐惧和后果的方法。因此，为了快速作结，我想问你这个问题，因为你在这个领域工作了很长时间。所以我想知道你的印象。你的总体印象是，事情正朝着积极的方向发展，还是消极的方向发展？你能看得出来吗？你知道，如果你看看当前我们现在正在目睹的事情，钟摆在前后摆动，从50年代到60年代开始，民权运动朝着一个方向发展，现在钟摆又反转了。我的意思是，你问我的不仅是一个科学问题，而是一个社会、政治问题。问题。让我快速谈谈我对这的想法。我们正在目睹的是……的增加
but still not take anti-biased actions because of the theory. and threat of the consequence sets that will come to you. And our research now really is looking at overcoming these fears and consequences. So just to wrap up quickly, I want to ask you this, because you've been working in this field for a long time. So I want to know your impression. Your overall impression, are things moving in a positive direction or a negative direction? Can you tell? You know, if you look currently, what we're witnessing now, and there's a pendulum swinging back and forth, beginning in the 50s to the 60, the civil rights movement going this one way, and now the pendulum reversing. I mean, you're asking me not just a scientific question, but a social, political. one. And let me give you my thoughts quickly on this. What we're witnessing in is an increase
偏见、盲目狂热、种族主义、性别歧视、恐同症的公开表达。你必须明白这里发生了什么。你知道，“让美国再次伟大”（MAGA）运动触及了一个泉源，美国许多人担心人口结构的不断变化，即在2030年至2050年之间的某个时候，人们将成为绝对多数。一种生活方式将不复存在。那么，“MAGA”这个标签含蓄地承诺了什么？那就是让美国再次变白！对。让美国再次回到LGBT个人还在《精神疾病诊断与统计手册》（DSM）中并被视为病态的时代。
in overt expressions of bias, bigotry, racism, sexism, homophobia. And you have to understand what has happened here. You know, the MAGA movement, Make America Great Again, was tapped into a wellspring that many in the United States feared the changing demographics, that sometime between the years 2030 and 2050, people will become a numerical majority. And a way of life would be lost. So what did the MAGA label implicitly promise it was make America white again? Right. Make America again a time where LGBT individuals were in the DSM and considered pathological.
再次让美国成为一个婚姻只存在于男人和女人之间的世界。再次让美国成为一个女性知道自己的本分而不是盛气凌人的时代。现在，这就是正在进行的元交流。在这场文化战争（他们这么叫它）中正在进行的战斗，将导致我认为在60年代和70年代纽瓦克和洛杉矶发生示威时发生的事情。
Make America again, a world in which marriage is between a man and a woman. Make America again a time where women knew their place and were not uppity. Now that's the meta-communications going on here. And the battle that is being fought here in the culture wars, they call them, is something that is going to lead to what I think happened in the 60s and 70s when the demonstrations occur in Newark, in Los Angeles. and, you know, I am optimistic by nature, but also realize that the pain and hurt that it's going to occur in this society may be a necessity necessity to improve our society. But we're in a major struggle right now, Kim. Well, Dr. Sue, I want to thank you for joining me today.
而且，你知道，我本质上也持乐观态度，但同时也意识到这个社会即将发生的痛苦和伤害可能是改善我们社会的必要条件。但我们现在正处于一场重大的斗争中，金。好的，苏博士，我想感谢你今天能来参加节目。
This has been really interesting. I appreciate the work that you are doing. Thank you so much. Okay, thank you. You can read more about microinterventions and strategies to combat microaggressions in APA's magazine, Monitor on Psychology. For links, visit our website at www.w.combeckycology.org. You can also find previous episodes there, or on Apple, Spotify, Stitcher, or wherever you get your podcasts. And if you like what you've heard, please leave us a review.
这真的非常有趣。我很欣赏你正在做的工作。非常感谢。好的，谢谢。你可以在美国心理学会的杂志《心理学观察》（Monitor on Psychology）上阅读更多关于微干预和打击微歧视策略的内容。获取链接请访问我们的网站 www.apa.org/monitor。你也可以在那里找到之前的节目，或者在 Apple、Spotify、Stitcher 或你获取播客的任何地方找到它们。如果你喜欢我们节目的内容，请给我们留下评论。
If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Wynerman. Our sound editor is Chris Condayan. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
如果您对未来的播客节目有任何意见或想法，可以发电子邮件至 speakingofpsychology@apa.org。《心理学谈话》由李·温纳曼（Lee Wynerman）制作。我们的音频剪辑师是克里斯·孔达扬（Chris Condayan）。感谢您的收听。我是美国心理协会的金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。